Prof: Okay,
so last time we were talking
about exponents,
and how statistics gives rise
to them.
And we looked last time at the
Boltzmann factor,
that e^-H/RT^( )or
ΔH/RT,
which tells you the temperature
dependence of the equilibrium
constant.
It gives you the equilibrium
constant;
remember at room temperatures
3/4thsΔH in
kilocalories.
Right?
And we saw last time that that
comes from counting arrangements
of a fixed number of energy
bits.
And the important thing is that
they're random,
that all of them are equally
likely.
<<Technical
adjustment>>
That has interesting
philosophical implications I
think.
Do you remember at the start of
the course we were talking about
types of authority,
and in particular,
remember, in Hamlet,
Act V, Scene II,
he says, "There's a
divinity that shapes our
ends."
So this was a traditional view
in society.
But then this guy came along,
in 1859.
Do you know who that is?
Charles Darwin,
with The Origin of the
Species.
So there was conflict between
the religious fundamentalists
and Darwinists that continues to
this day.
But I think they really miss
the point, because Darwin had
the idea that things were
developing and getting better
all the time.
Right?
So there's a certain
compatibility between that and
the sensibilities of the
fundamentalists.
But also, not too long from
then, this guy came along,
Boltzmann, and he said
everything is driven just by
randomness.
There's no goal for everything.
That should be the real
conflict, between religious
fundamentalists and science,
is Boltzmann.
But so few people understand
what Boltzmann did that there's
no reason for the conflict.
At any rate,
we saw where the Boltzmann
factor came from,
in terms of statistics.
Then there's the entropy
factor, which we saw last time.
And notice that,
as I've written it here,
in the top equation,
the one with Boltzmann,
there's an R,
and the one at the bottom has a
k.
Sometimes you see R's
and sometimes see k's.
They're actually the same thing.
The k is if you measure
the energy per molecule,
and R is if you measure
the energy per mole.
So all you have is Avogadro's
number is included in one of
them and not the other.
They're really the same thing,
these two exponentials.
But at any rate,
we can cancel the T's
and know that that
e^S/k^( )is a counting
number, W;
the number of molecular
structures being grouped.
And we saw that at the end of
last time in terms of gauche-
versus anti-butane.
And remember that S = ln
k -- which is the same
equation, just the log on each
side -- is on Boltzmann's tomb.
But let's look at one more
example, in terms of
cyclohexane.
Do you remember the cyclohexane
conorformers --
<<technical
adjustment>>
-- remember the cyclohexane
conformers, if it's a chair,
it's very rigid.
Why is it rigid?
Do you remember?
Why is it hard to twist?
With respect to the molecular
model, why is it hard to twist?
Eric?
Why does this particular model,
in which rotation around bonds
is completely free,
why is it hard to rotate to go
like this?
Why is there a click?
Student:
>.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  It has the
optimal bending angles,
109.5.
Prof: Ah,
it's the bending angle that has
to flatten out when you do this.
Remember we talked about that.
But anyhow this one is very
rigid.
But if you click it,
into the boat,
then it's actually a twist-boat
and it turns to all sorts of
structures ever so easily.
So there are many more
accessible structures for a
boat, than there are for a
chair.
The chair, you have this one
and you have this one.
Right?
But for a boat,
or a twisted,
or the "flexible"
form as it's often called,
you have lots and lots of
accessible structures.
What's that going to mean in
terms of entropy?
That there are many more
structures you're going to count
for the flexible form than you
count for the chair form,
the rigid form.
Okay?
So if we look at -- this is a
picture of the energy with the
chair at the minimum of energy.
The twist-boat is 5.5
kilocalories above,
but it has very small barriers
among different twist-boat
forms.
So we would say there are few
structures that are chair
cyclohexane, but many structures
that are the boat.
And furthermore,
if we look at it in terms of
quantum mechanics,
which is the real way to do it,
we notice that when there's a
steep,
stiff valley,
there are very few energy
levels that are accessible.
Right?
But if the barriers are low,
then there are many,
many quantum levels.
So you count many more quantum
levels for the flexible form
than you do for the chair form.
What that means is from,
whether the red classical view
or the green quantum view,
there's a big statistical
factor, an entropy factor,
which turns out to be about
7-fold favoring the twist-boat
over the chair.
The chair is still favored;
it's favored because of energy,
that Boltzmann factor,
e^ΔH/kT.
But this reduces that bias in
favor of the chair -- which
would otherwise be 10^3/4ths of
5.5; right?
-- it reduces it by about a
factor of 2000.
So the equilibrium constant is
only 14,000 -- instead of
14,000, it reduces by a factor
of 7, to make it 2000.
Okay, so that's -- but so we've
been talking about entropy here
in statistical terms.
But remember earlier we talked
about the fact that physical
chemists actually measure
entropy as something
experimental,
not just a counting exercise,
and they do it beginning with
something that's as close as
possible to zero Kelvin.
Because if you have a perfectly
ordered crystal,
at zero Kelvin,
then there's only one structure
you're talking about.
Right?
So the entropy is the log of
one, which is zero,
or log of 1/R;
times R.
Okay?
So it's zero.
But then as you warm it up,
as you put heat in,
you measure the increase in
this thing called entropy by how
much heat you put in,
at each temperature,
as you warm up.
And we talked about that
already.
And you'll notice qualitatively
how this works is that floppy
molecules,
like the flexible form of
cyclohexane,
that have many closely spaced
energy levels,
absorb more energy,
and they absorb it at lower
temperatures,
and thus they have more entropy
when they get warmed.
So whether you do it
experimentally,
by measuring the heat that gets
absorbed,
or whether you measure it by
counting quantum states,
you get the same result;
that a floppy molecule is
favored in terms of entropy.
We talked about that when we
were talking about the barrier
to ethane rotation.
Okay, so we've looked at the
Boltzmann factor and this
entropy factor,
that come from counting.
Notice that in the second case,
truly we should be counting not
structures but quantum states;
how many states are there that
count?
And if you want to be really,
really picky,
you say the weighted number of
quantum states;
because ones that are higher in
energy are not as populated as
ones that are lower in energy.
But we don't have to worry
about that now.
At any rate,
those two factors,
taken together,
are what gives the equilibrium
constant,
which as we said before is
e^-ΔG,
free energy;
that means it's both enthalpy,
heat, and entropy,
this counting thing.
But there's more to it than
that.
There's also the statistics
involved in the Law of Mass
Action.
And that comes from counting
molecules per volume;
that is, concentration.
So you can count energy,
you can count quantum states,
and you can count molecules per
volume.
This is very easily understood.
The way it developed
experimentally is that in the
late 1700s there was an attempt
to assemble a hierarchy of
affinities;
that some elements had more
affinity than others.
So if you had a compound that
involved one element,
and mixed it with an element
that had higher affinity,
that one with higher affinity
would take away molecules from
the one with lower affinity.
But then it was found,
in the early 1800s,
that it doesn't always go in
that direction,
because concentrations can
change and make things go the
wrong way,
toward something that's a very
low affinity,
if it has very high
concentration.
And by the middle 1800s,
this was formulated as an
equilibrium constant,
K, which was understood
as the balance between forward
reactions and reverse reactions.
You've seen that k_1/k_-1
is the equilibrium constant.
So concentration comes into it,
in this thing called the Law of
Mass Action.
If you have two A's that can go
to A_2,
then you have this equilibrium
constant,
written as the concentration of
A_2 divided by the concentration
of A^2.
Now why the exponent?
Where does that exponent two
come from?
And sometimes it's three.
Remember?
Again, it's statistical and
very, very easy to see.
Here I used Excel to place a
bunch of circles randomly on a
two-dimenstional plot.
So it put 50 of these circles
down.
And we're going to count as
dimers things where they
overlap, where they touch one
another.
Okay?
So there's -- if you have 50
particles, this particular
realization of randomness gave
one dimer.
But suppose we add another 50.
Right?
Now, in addition to the
original dimer,
there are 8 more.
Okay?
And now suppose I add another
50, now there are 19 dimers.
Or another 50;
now there are 35 dimers.
Or another 50,
and now there are 59 dimers.
Now let's make a plot of how
many dimers there are,
compared to how many particles
there are, undimerized ones.
So there's the number of
particles and the number of
dimers, plotted;
the data there.
And you see what it is.
It's a parabola;
that the number of dimers is
proportional to the square of
the number of monomers.
Now why should that be so?
It's because as you increase
the concentration,
you increase the number of
units there; obviously.
That's by definition.
But you also increase the
fraction of the units that have
a near neighbor,
that are touching.
So not only do you increase the
number that could be dimers,
you increase the fraction that
are dimers.
So there are two ways in which
increasing the concentration
increases the dimer.
Right?
So it's a square.
That's where the exponent comes
in.
It's purely statistical,
for random distribution.
And then, of course,
energy can enter in,
entropy can enter in.
That will change the K.
But the exponent on P --
right?
-- is due just to this counting
procedure.
So you increase both the number
and the fraction that are
dimers.
Okay, so now we know about
equilibrium, statistics and
exponents.
We have particle distribution,
that's the law of mass action;
that's that square we just
talked about.
We have energy distribution,
ΔH,
the Boltzmann factor.
And we have counting of quantum
states, which has to do with
entropy.
Okay, so free energy determines
what equilibrium is,
what can happen.
Right?
And that ΔG
remember includes both entropy
and energy.
But it doesn't tell you at all
how quickly it will happen,
what the kinetics of the
reaction are.
So for that purpose we're going
to try visualizing reactions,
to see if we can get a picture
of what determines rates.
And we're going to look at two
kinds of things.
We're going to look at
classical trajectories,
and at the potential energy
surface, and collective
concepts.
So first let's start with the
potential energy surface.
Here's a very simple potential
energy surface.
It's just a two-dimensional
diagram.
So you've seen it before.
We plot the distance between
two atoms, A-B,
and the potential energy as a
function of the distance.
So this is a Morse-type curve.
Okay, so we put a ball on it,
and let that ball roll to map
out different distances,
as it moves -- that's the
horizontal axis --
and the energy corresponding to
that distance.
So it rolls back and forth --
right?
-- mapping out the change in
geometry horizontally,
and the change in energy
vertically.
Now we're going to look at a
three-dimensional surface,
or actually two geometrical
dimensions;
plus the third dimension coming
out at you, the contours,
have to do with potential
energy, of three particles now.
But in order to describe the
position of three particles,
you need three distances;
one to two, two to three,
and three to one.
Right?
So that's too many dimensions
to plot this way.
So we're going to assume that
they're all on a line.
So we only have the distance
between one and two,
and the distance between two
and three.
So two coordinates will tell
you what the arrangement of
those three atoms are,
if they're in just one
dimension.
Okay, so a linear triatomic,
A-B-C.
On the horizontal distance we
have the distance A to B,
on the vertical axis,
B to C, and the contours tell
us how low the energy is;
the darker, the lower the
energy.
Okay, so this specifies the
structure.
So the position of a point
specifies not the position of an
atom but the position of a set
of atoms.
Right?
So as we move one point around,
we're moving two atoms,
or changing two distances.
But we can denote it with one
point here, in two geometric
dimensions.
Okay, so let's look at several
regions.
Let's look at that valley on
the right.
What is that valley?
When a point is in that valley,
what's it describing?
It says that the distance
between A and B is large.
Right?
So A is far away from B.
What does it say about the BC
distance?
It's short.
It's the normal distance for a
BC molecule.
So what is it;
when a point is in that valley,
what geometry is it describing?
It's describing a BC molecule,
with an A atom at a great
distance from it,
depending on how far out we go
to the right.
Does everybody see that?
One position of the point tells
us where both -- where all three
atoms are, as long as they're on
a line.
Right?
Now how about up there,
on that plateau?
What's happening there?
What's the physical system?
Maria, what do you say?
Student:  All the atoms
are separate from each other.
Prof: Yeah,
the atoms are all separate from
one another.
C is far from B and A is far
from B.
So there the atoms are
separated.
And it's high in energy.
You're not surprised that it
takes energy to pull them apart.
And there is a cliff. Right?
If this were a hiking map,
that would be a cliff.
What does that cliff mean?
Why is there a cliff there?
Greg, what do you say?
Why is there a cliff shown
there?
What's the geometry that points
in that region described?
Student:  Closer
together.
Prof: What's close
together?
Is A close to B?
Student:  Closer.
Prof: Is A close to B?
I couldn't hear.
Student:  Closer maybe
to B.
Prof: No.
Here's the distance A-B.
It's way out there,
where that cliff is.
Right?
So A's far away.
But what's happening?
B and C are getting very close
to one another.
So that's a collision between B
and C;
much shorter than their bond
distance.
Right?
They're being scrunched
together in that region,
and that's why the energy goes
up very rapidly,
because they're running into
one another;
closer than they like to be.
There's a ridge -- right?
-- as you go down there.
If you were hiking,
that would be a ridge.
And there's a special point on
the ridge, which is marked by
the red cross.
What would you call that if you
were hiking?
If you were in the valley
that's labeled yellow,
and you were thinking of
getting to the other valley,
what would you call that cross,
if you were hiking?
Student:  A peak.
Prof: Not a peak. Right?
It comes -- it gets high as it
gets close to me here,
and it gets high out on the
plateau.
It's actually low,
as we go along the line,
but it's high as we go
perpendicular to the line.
What would you call that if you
were hiking?
Some of you must hike.
Student:  A pass.
Prof: Pardon me?
Prof: It's a pass,
between one valley and the
other valley.
That's the way you would go if
you were hiking -- right?
-- so you don't have to climb
so high.
Okay, so it's a pass.
Or in chemistry we call it a
transition state,
or a transition structure.
And it's like a potato chip.
Right?
It's a minimum in one
direction, along the ridge,
but it's a maximum in the path
between the two valleys.
Okay?
So it's a very special point.
Okay, now let's look at this a
little closer.
Suppose we sliced this surface,
we took a knife and sliced it
along the red line there,
horizontally,
and then folded it back to look
at the cross-section.
Does everybody see what I'm
saying?
What would the cross-section
look like?
It's exactly that one we looked
at before.
So that involves stretching A
and B, with C so far away that
it's irrelevant.
Right?
So it's just stretching a
diatomic molecule.
Or if we sliced -- so that's
vibration of AB,
with a distant spectator of
C.***Okay?
Now suppose we sliced it that
way and pulled it back.
Now what is it?
It's a vibrating BC molecule,
with A far away.
Right?
So again, by choosing points on
this, we can describe any
geometry of these three points
we want, as long as they're on a
line.
But a single point is a whole
structure.
Okay, now let's look at a
trajectory.
We roll a ball on this surface,
and it rolls up toward the pass
but doesn't make it and comes
back like that.
So that's a trajectory that was
unreactive;
it didn't make it into the
product valley,
it didn't get across the ridge.
And physically what it means is
that A gets closer to BC.
While BC is vibrating,
it's moving up and down.
Right?
So BC is vibrating.
A comes in and then bounces off
again.
Right?
So it was an unsuccessful
attempt of A to take B away from
C.
Or suppose we do this one.
A approaches,
and now C flies away from
vibrating AB.
Does everybody see that?
You want me to say it again?
Right?
So as it comes along,
B and C are standing still.
It's not moving vertically,
right?
So B and C are at their normal
distance, their standard
distance.
A comes in, whops into it,
gets really close,
runs into that cliff,
really close to B,
because it's the distance A-B.
Right?
And then it starts -- AB is
vibrating, and C is getting far
away, as it goes down the
product valley.
So that's a reactive
trajectory, where the first
trajectory was unreactive.
Notice that this is classical,
rolling a marble on the thing,
because A was approaching a
non-vibrating BC.
We know from quantum mechanics
that BC can't just sit there.
BC vibrates.
So that's not a realistic
trajectory, it's a classical
model of a quantum mechanical
system.
Now people have made surfaces
like that for real systems,
like H_3, one hydrogen atom
attacking a hydrogen molecule
and taking one of the hydrogens
away.
Here it is.
This was drawn.
This is the first surface that
was drawn, that I know of,
by Henry Eyring at Princeton in
1935.
And it had some -- it has crazy
angles.
And the reason it has that
angle is so that a marble
rolling on it will behave
according to the way the masses
of the thing --
so that the kinetics,
the kinematics,
are exactly right,
so that it really does do the
proper classical thing.
If you roll a marble on here,
it will trace Newton's Laws of
Motion, for this H_3 system.
One thing that's unrealistic
about it is that there's a
minimum near the transition
state.
There's a little lake up there.
That's just an artifact that
came from the equation he used
to approximate the surface.
It's not real.
There actually is a potato
chip, not a lake up there at the
pass.
Some people have called it Lake
Eyring.
Okay?
But here's a more complicated
surface that was -- it says it
was done by C. Parr,
in his Ph.D.
thesis at Caltech in 1969.
This is for H-H-Br;
again linear,
but a hydrogen atom attacking
HBr to take away it's hydrogen.
And this describes the
construction of a model based on
that surface,
an actual physical model on
which you can roll marbles.
Right?
So here it is,
and the dimensions,
that one inch corresponds to
1.4 inches is an angstrom,
and so on.
So they actually constructed
physical models to do this.
And, as it happens,
we have that physical model
here.
Here, this is it.
<<Technical
adjustment>>
Okay, and we have some marbles.
So notice what's different
about this one.
I'll hold it up so you can see
it.
There's the surface. Right?
And here's a slice through one.
Right?
That's H_2 with -- this valley
is H_2 with a Br atom.
This valley is HBr,
with an H atom.
Right?
So we can try rolling balls and
see what happens here.
So here I am far away.
The H atom is far away from HBr.
And I do that.
And it's vibrating,
but it doesn't succeed.
Right?
I can do it a little bit more.
And most reactions aren't
successful.
Oh close. Okay?
And as it comes out,
it may be vibrating when it
comes out, or it may not be
vibrating when it comes -- oh.
What's the cross?
The cross is that transition
structure -- right?
-- or the transition state.
Right?
So you could do every possible
trajectory.
You could have different
velocities at which A is
colliding with BC,
and you can have different
amounts of vibration,
and different phases of
vibration.
I could start it going this
way, or I could start it going
this way.
And if I did every possible one
of those, then I could average
over all them and see how many
of them succeeded -- right?
-- in reaction.
And that would allow me to
predict the rate of this
process.
<<Technical
adjustment>>
Okay, so people have done that
kind of thing.
But studying lots of random
trajectories provides too much
detail.
No one really cares about all
those individual trajectories.
What you care about is what
fraction succeed.
And if you could do that in a
simpler way than rolling it a
zillion times and averaging,
then that would be a better
approach.
So it's better to summarize
this thing statistically using
collective terms;
not individual paths but
collective terms,
such as enthalpy and entropy.
And you can do it in this way.
Okay, you have a steepest
descent path from the pass.
Suppose you slice this surface
with a knife perpendicular to
the screen,
along that path,
and then fold it out to make it
flat,
and look at the cross-section
of it.
Okay, and now we'll tip it up
and it looks like that.
Does everybody see how it looks
like that?
Okay, we sliced along the path
that goes up over the transition
state.
Okay, so we have potential
energy as a function of distance
along the reaction coordinate.
But of course we're going to
summarize a whole bunch of
things here.
Nothing rolls exactly along
that path.
Right?
So we're going to lose some of
the specificity of the reaction
coordinate by grouping things.
We're not going to take a
trajectory, but a sequence of
three species.
The first species is the
starting material;
the second species is the
transition state;
and the third species is the
product.
And now instead of having an
explicit meaning for every
geometry along that path,
what we're going to do is
associate each of those starting
materials,
transition state and products,
with a certain enthalpy and a
certain entropy;
that is, a certain free energy.
So we have -- instead we're
going to plot free energy
vertically,
incorporate entropy -- that is,
how loose these things are --
as well as enthalpy there;
energy.
And now we just have three
values of free energy:
the free energy of the starting
material;
the free energy of the
transition state;
the free energy of the product.
And now we can use those -- but
we've lost a lot of specificity
in what the reaction coordinate
is.
It's just a sequence now of
three species.
But we can now use free energy
to determine what can happen.
We already could do that.
But how rapidly?
And you do that with the theory
that Eyring made up when he drew
that surface in 1935,
called Transition State Theory.
You assume that the rate
constant -- and we talked about
this before -- in units per
second is 10^13th.
So things happen
10^13th/second,
times the concentration of the
transition state.
So the idea is that things that
are in the transition state are
moving at the rate
10^13th/second.
So if you know how many are at
the transition state,
then you know how many are
going to product;
10^13th times that,
per second.
Right?
And you know how to do an
equilibrium;
we already do that.
All we do is use that special
double dagger,
to mean the difference in
energy going from the starting
material to the transition
state,
the difference in free energy.
Now we can calculate that
equilibrium constant.
We know how much starting
material there is;
the Law of Mass Action.
We know how much transition
state there is in equilibrium
with that starting material.
Right?
So that e^-ΔG/RT
is the equilibrium constant for
getting the transition state;
multiply it by the
concentration of the starting
material.
You have the concentration of
the transition state.
Multiply it by 10^13th,
and you know how fast it's
going.
Right?
So it assumes that there's a
universal rate constant for
transition states going to the
product;
10^13th/second.
That's about how fast things
vibrate.
So things won't stay on the
potato chip, they'll roll off,
and the rate at which they roll
off is 10^13th/second.
This is, of course,
an approximation.
It isn't correct.
Because there's not true
equilibrium between the
transition state and the
starting material.
For true equilibrium the same
number must be going in and out.
Right?
But when things get to the
transition state,
often they keep going,
they don't come back.
So it's not really a rigorous
theory, but it's a very,
very helpful theory for
approximate purposes.
And that's what I say here.
Okay?
So using energies to predict
equilibria and rates for
one-step reactions;
free radical halogenations.
And let me look,
we do have time to go through
this stuff, I think;
at least most of it.
We've already seen this,
that you break a chlorine
molecule into two atoms.
Then you do single electron
curved arrows;
take the hydrogen away from
methyl --
from methane,
to give methyl,
and then it attacks chlorine --
we've seen this before -- and
the chlorine atom comes back to
constitute a chain reaction.
Okay?
So it's catalytic in radicals.
Okay, now we break and make
bonds in this.
So we've already seen average
bond energies that might tell us
how hard it is to break a bond
-- right?
-- if that's what we have to do
to get to the transition state.
So we may be on the way to
getting rates.
But are these average bond
energies real bond energies,
or are they just a trick for
reckoning the enthalpy,
the total energy,
the heat of formation or
whatever,
of a particular molecule?
And we talked about this before
and saw that mostly it is a
trick;
that individual bond energies
change.
Right?
So average bond energies are
not what you want to use for
this purpose;
although they might be in the
ballpark of the right numbers,
but they're not the right
numbers.
What you really need are bond
dissociation energies;
the actual energy it takes to
break a specific bond.
And we've talked about how you
could get that from
spectroscopy.
Those are real.
The average bond energies are
just a way of calculating
molecular energy.
So Appendix II of the
Streitwieser and Heathcock book
shows various specific bonds
between the groups in column A
and the atoms or groups in row A
there,
in the top row.
And those were the best values
when that book was published;
the best values as of 2003 are
a little bit changed from that,
and were tabulated by Barney
Ellison, whose picture I showed
you the time before last.
So here's a table from Blanksby
and Ellison, that shows a bunch
of these things and how well
they're known.
The H_2 bond dissociation
energy is 104.206,
plus or minus 0.003
kilocalories/mol.
So it's very well-known.
So some of them are very,
very well-known,
and some of them are known only
approximately.
Let's look at a few of them.
So H_2 104.2;
HF 136;
HCl 103;
HBr 87;
HI 71.
So as you go down the halogens,
the bonds get weaker and
weaker.
Why should that be?
Why do larger halogens give
weaker bonds?
It's because they have poorer
overlap with hydrogen,
at normal bond distances,
because their orbitals are very
diffuse;
they don't have high numbers in
the region where the hydrogen
is.
And you have the energy match
also is unfavorable.
So if you have HF,
with good overlap and a very
low F, then you get lots of
stabilization;
the sum or those two red arrows
is big, a strong bond.
And if it's HI,
the overlap isn't so good,
and the energy match is better.
But still the amount by which
the electrons go down is not as
much as with HF.
So we can see qualitatively why
that is.
So less electron stabilization
means a weaker bond.
And we're going to talk about
this more next semester.
This is just to give you a
flavor of it.
And here, in Table II,
we see there's the same trend
in bonding with methyl groups;
that the fluorine-methyl bond
is 115, but the iodine-methyl
bond is only 58.
But if you go across hydrogen
with the different alkyls --
methyl, ethyl,
isopropyl, t-butyl --
they're all very close to 100
kilocalories/mol.
But not the same,
and that will turn out to make
a difference;
as we'll see early next
semester.
And if you look at some of the
other kinds of radicals,
you see there are differences.
There are special cases for
vinyl, allyl -- remember allyl
alcohol -- phenyl and benzyl.
And I'll show you just a little
bit about that.
Are these unusual bond
dissociation energy values due
to unusual bonds or unusual
radicals?
That is, standard we have:
here's a starting material;
here's the bond;
here's the product as the
bond's broken -- for making the
radicals.
So we can get a strong bond,
either by lowering -- by making
the bond strong,
or by making the radicals bad;
either way increases the
barrier.
Right?
Similarly we can make a small
one, either by making the bond
weak or making the radical
stable.
Is this something that it's
meaningful to talk about?
Well let's look at it in the
case of these special cases.
So vinyl, you see,
is 110 kilocalories/mol.
It's the bond to H.
So it's a very strong bond. Why?
Is there something special
about the vinyl radical?
There's no special
stabilization.
There's no overlap between that
singly occupied orbital,
which is a σ
orbital,
and the double bond,
which is a π orbital.
There's nothing especially
stable about the vinyl radical.
But if you look at the bond in
the starting material,
the C-H bond,
it has sp^2
hybridization of the carbon.
So that one's a strong bond.
That one's hard to break,
because the bond is unusually
strong;
not because the radicals are
unusually unstable.
Okay?
Or if you look at phenyl,
it's the same deal.
You have a σ SOMO
and the π bonds,
the low LUMOs that might
stabilize that singly occupied
orbital's electron,
are perpendicular or orthogonal
to it.
So again it's hard to break
that bond.
On the other hand,
the allyl -- and remember allyl
alcohol we were talking about --
here's an allyl radical.
Now there's overlap,
π overlap between the
SOMO and the π* and
the π.
It turns out -- and we'll talk
about this more next time --
that when you mix those two,
the π* on the right
and the SOMO in the middle,
you get stabilization.
You get the same stabilization
by mixing the π with
the SOMO, and if you mix both of
them with the SOMO,
you get that structure.
But this isn't the time to talk
about that.
But at any rate,
the normal, the starting bond,
is normal.
It's an sp^3 C-H bond,
a normal bond.
But in this case the radical is
unusually stable.
So it's easy to break that one;
10 kilocalories easier than for
normal C-H bonds.
And the same for benzyl.
Okay, now possibility of doing
a halogenation.
Let's look first from the point
of view of the equilibrium
constant from this,
at the difference in energy
between starting material and
product.
So we look at what bonds are
broken, and what bonds are
formed.
The red bonds are broken,
the green bonds are formed.
So there'll be a cost for
breaking the red bonds and
there'll be a return for making
the green bonds.
And let's see how big it is.
Okay, we're going to do it for
fluorine, chlorine,
bromine and iodine.
Okay, in every case we're
breaking a C-H bond,
105 kilocalories/mol,
and we're breaking a
halogen-halogen bond.
But those are different,
for the different halogens;
although interestingly not
monotonic.
It's not a smooth progression,
it goes up and then down again.
And the cost is the sum of
those two;
what it's going to cost to
break those bonds.
How about making bonds?
We're going to make the C-X
bond and we're going to make the
H-X bond.
So the returns will be that.
And now we see whether we can
make a living doing this.
What will the profit be? Right?
So in the case of fluorine,
251 is much greater than the
cost of 142.
So it's a big -- it's really
exothermic.
Right?
Chlorine, it's only 19.
Bromine is only 9,
and iodine is
minus 12.
What does that mean?
It means you can't do this
reaction with iodine.
The equilibrium lies is in the
wrong direction.
Okay, so already the
equilibrium constant and how
energy relates to it tells you
that something is impossible to
do.
But the others seem to be
possible.
But will they happen?
How fast will they be?
Do you have to wait until the
end of the universe in order for
this to happen?
Well let's look at how the
rate, which will depend on the
mechanism.
The equilibrium constant
doesn't depend on the path.
It's just how high the starting
material is and how high the
product is.
But how fast you get depends on
the barriers you have to go
across.
So let's suppose -- let's just
try breaking two bonds,
changing partners,
and forming two bonds.
Okay?
Then we have to -- to get to
the barrier, we have to break
two bonds.
So that cost -- we're going to
have to spend,
in order to get to the barrier.
So is this a plausible
mechanism?
How fast would the reaction be,
if we used that mechanism?
Well at room temperature,
say 300 Kelvin,
then it's 10^3/4ths of how high
it is to get there;
then times 10^13th/second.
But notice that 10^13th times
10^-106, which is 3/4ths of 142,
is 10^-93/second.
10^93^( )seconds is a long,
long time.
I don't know how old the
universe is, but I suspect
that's longer.
Right?
So what about this mechanism?
Plausible?
Implausible?
How could you make it happen?
Shai?
Student:  Change the
temperature.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  Change the
temperature.
Prof: Change the
temperature;
because we can change that
3/4ths to something else by --
to a much smaller number -- by
increasing the temperature.
So no way to do that one.
But if we go to 3000 Kelvin,
then it's 250 reactions per
second.
So that's quite feasible,
as long as nothing else
happens;
something else might be even
faster.
Right?
But at least this mechanism
could work, if you were in a
flame say, or in Professor
Chupka's oven,
that we talked about last time.
Okay, now let's look at
Eyring's H + H_2 here.
So we want to get from this
valley to the other valley.
How do we do it?
This mechanism would be to
break a bond and then -- so
dissociation and then
association.
But uh, it's very slow to get
up there -- right?
-- to get up to that plateau of
breaking a bond.
There's a much easier way to
get from one valley to the
other.
What is it?
Go through the pass. Right?
So instead of doing that slow
reaction, you can do this much
faster reaction,
making a new bond as you break
the old one.
So you don't have to pay all
the cost of breaking the old
one, and you're getting
something back for it.
So you can have a free radical
chain substitution,
where you have an X atom -- and
we've talked about this before.
Take the H away from R.
Then the R group takes away X
from X_2.
And it can just go round and
round.
There's this machine,
very much like the machine that
Professor Sharpless talked
about, that goes around and
around.
You feed in starting material,
and the products come out.
And you don't -- it's a
catalyst;
you don't have to go to such
high energies as you normally
would have to do.
So the possibility of
halogenation -- here we looked
at it at equilibrium and saw
that forget it with iodine;
the others look okay.
And for a mechanism with a
reasonable rate,
we could change those two
columns, exchange them,
so that we make the H-X,
as we break CH_3-H --
so the X atom helps you do that
-- and that generates then a
CH_3 group,
which helps the reaction on the
right.
So now, step one,
how much energy do you have to
put in?
You're paying 105 but you're
getting back 136.
So that's great. Right?
The first step seems plausible
now;
although you don't know how
high the barrier is that you
have to get from starting
material to product.
But at least it's much easier.
So the top one,
it looks good all around.
The chlorine and bromine will
be a little touchy,
on those first two steps,
because they're uphill in
energy.
But step two is good in all
cases.
Okay, so what we need to do is
be able to predict activation
energy.
But Rome wasn't built in a day,
and that's going to happen next
semester, to get into this and
to talk in more detail about
these catalytic reactions.
Notice that this is exactly the
kind of thing Sharpless was
talking about.
If you could find a way of
lowering one of these barriers,
then the catalytic cycle would
work.
He was saying,
remember, that it was
democratic;
that all the steps,
as you go around the cycle,
have to be at the same -- go at
the same rate,
or else everything stops up,
stops and waits before it tries
to get over some big step.
So you have to have all the
steps be fast;
and that's why he was saying
that that diisopropylethylamine
helped the formation of
omeprazole.
Well so we've been doing
organic chemistry this semester.
Some people might doubt that.
There'll be no doubt next
semester that everyone will
agree that what we do is organic
chemistry.
We're going to talk about the
chemistry of functional groups
and sugars and amino acids and
all carbonyl groups and esters;
all these things.
But there's a reason that it's
been a little different this
semester.
We've talked mostly about
physical-organic chemistry.
And the reason is because of
where I came from;
that I did my Ph.D.
-- and in fact I took a course
as an undergraduate with Paul
Bartlett at Harvard.
And as you've seen from our
common ancestry,
he was a physical-organic
chemist;
more interested in how
reactions work than in what you
can make.
Okay, so there's this book that
came out in 1939,
went through at least three
editions --
I have the Second and Third
Editions here --
which is called The Nature
of the Chemical Bond.
And this was a fabulously
influential book;
even if it is the one that said
it was 126 kilocalories/mol,
to take carbon away from
graphite, when we know it's 171.
So Pauling was arguably the
most influential chemist of the
Twentieth Century.
He got two Nobel Prizes.
>
Recording of Professor Jack
Dunitz:  At the time when I
was reading that book I was
wondering whether chemistry was
really as interesting as I had
hoped it was going to be.
And I think I was almost ready
to give it up and do something
else.
I didn't care very much for
this chemistry which was full of
facts and recipes and very
little thought in it,
very little intellectual
structure.
And Pauling's book gave me a
glimpse of what the future of
chemistry was going to be and
particularly,
perhaps, my future.
Prof: Right, okay.
So that's what we've been doing
the first semester,
is this kind of thing,
thinking about the chemical
bond.
We started with wondering,
with Newton,
whether there was an atomic
force law, and then we looked to
see if we could see bonds,
or feel them.
And then we tried to understand
bonding and reactivity,
through the Schrödinger
equation;
which most people believe is
the fundamental way to
understand things properly.
And then we learned how
chemists learned to treasure the
molecular model.
Things like this,
that turned out to be really,
really useful tools --
composition,
constitution,
configuration,
and conformation --
and finally energy. Right?
So I hope that we've this
semester,
if we haven't done as much
organic chemistry as some people
would care for,
that at least we've raised some
big questions;
like how does science know
things?
Right?
Or, compared to what?
Those are the really big
questions.
But even if we're only focusing
on the specific content of the
course, interested in bonds,
here are two questions for you
to think about.
Were chemical bonds discovered
or were they invented?
To what extent are chemical
bonds real?
Or to what extent are they a
figment of a chemist's
imagination?
This is the kind of thing we've
been aiming at all semester.
So you should be in a position
to think about this now.
Or would we even have chemical
bonds, without our own chemical
forbearers?
So we've looked at how the idea
of bonds and these different
properties of bonds developed.
But suppose chemistry was
developing in some other solar
system.
Right?
What would happen there?
Suppose people discovered the
Schrödinger equation,
before they had the idea of
bonds.
Would bonds have been necessary?
Is chemistry going to evolve,
such that all you need do is
put stuff into a computer,
solve quantum mechanics,
and forget about bonds?
Okay?
The answers to these questions
aren't obvious,
but they're good ones to think
about.
So this is the end,
and good luck on the final.
Are you fired up?
Students:  Yeah.
Prof: Are you ready to
go?
Good.
Thanks.